se vi state chiedendo perché mi sono
messo questo cappello e perché sono
convinto che mi faccia parecchio più
intelligente
[Musica]
ok no bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
finalmente cazzo siamo il nuovo blog e
dalle 22 di febbraio che non faccio mica
un mezzo è pazzesco praticamente ragazzi
non ho più fatto blog da da circa un
mese perché prima inter haga in questi
ultimi mesi di scuola mi stanno
bombardando penso a tutti ma comunque in
particolare perché ciò la maturità a
chiunque ragazzi nonostante questo ho
appena finito di studiare appena finito
di studiare giuro adesso riuscito a
trovare il tempo per fortuna e quindi
ragazzi finalmente siamo il nuovo blog
non non pensavo di poterlo dire in
quest'epoca e partiamo col afona della
settimana ragazzi che questa settimana è
stata vinta da elisa che ha fatto sta
spagnola parlare value che è riuscito a
rappresentare anche benissimo il numero
di testate chiedo al muro quando faccio
si giochi se no il numero di morti di
che magari va bene e quindi negativi di
passare alle news subito perché no
umilia la gatti c'hanno 250 devo dirle
subito che non sono lunghe ma devo
innanzitutto volevo fare una cosa che
volevo fare da tempo non l'ho mai fatta
perché non ho mai trovato tempo ma
allora lo speciale 200mila iscritti mi
pare quello che avevo fatto
scribblenauts nella vita reale mi aveva
aiutato a farlo
maurizio valente e i ragazzi che hanno
il canale pixar su youtube e volevo
ringraziarli tantissimo per avermi
aiutato prima velico nostro siamo anche
amici quindi ragazzi volevo non ha mai
avuto l'occasione pro volevo
consigliarvi perché sono veramente dei
grandissimi youtuber e si sono prestati
a registrare come al freddo perché era
dicembre
io ero in maniche corte loro no però io
sì io ho sofferto di più ma comunque
ragazzi volevo ringraziarli da un casino
di tempo e ho trovato finalmente il
tempo di farlo quindi volevo
ringraziarli e la lascio il link nella
descrizione se volete passare sul loro
canale comunque raga io stento stento a
crederci ma siamo arrivati
c'è una cosa astuto ragazzi non ci posso
credere 600 foto più semi mila iscritti
è una cosa pazzesca ciao ragazzi non ci
posso credere è ormai diventato a
mainstream dire non ci posso credere
perché lo dico ogni volta
ma non ci posso credere ho voluto fare
lo speciale 600.000 po prima l'avevo
fatto quello dello speciale dove
mangiava la nutella su over gloss non
avete visto lasciarli che la descrizione
anche di quello ma niente di ciò che
avevo un'improvvisa voglia di nutella
quindi ho approfittato del momento poi
mi ha un po senza la voglia di mangiarla
comunque non importa nonostante questo
ragazzi farò comunque uno speciale più
avanti perché gli do particolare i no da
mettere in una maniera incredibile
perché mi sono studiato le cose
pazzesche e quindi niente ragazzi vi
ringrazio per il trovarvi incredibile
allora siccome sono impegnatissimo con
la scuola e quindi come vi ho detto
prima non è veramente è difficilissimo
trovare il tempo per fare tutte le cose
le avevo promesso che in questo periodo
avrei fatto di tanti raduni in giro per
l'italia diciamo come ho fatto ad ascoli
però per ragazzi purtroppo non riesco a
farlo perché questi ultimi mesi di
scuola sono massacranti per me perché
ciò la maturità e quindi lega visto che
non mi posso muovere più di tanto deciso
di farne soltanto più uno in questo
periodo qui che lo farò appunto a torino
al centro commerciale snos perché
diciamocelo vicino quindi ho chiesto se
si poteva perché io li faccio lì almeno
se piove siamo al riparo e non siamo
condizionati dalla grandine i tuoni zeus
l'apocalisse ma la cosa che non sapevo e
che effettivamente hanno messo la
pubblicità sui sui pullman già una cosa
io visto visto passare due o tre pullman
la mia faccia ci sono rimasto malissimo
ho detto ok c'è qualcosa di strano che
poi dall'altro ragazzi la foto è questa
c'è del tipo di beni invisibili a sto
punto appello dico comunque ci sarà
l'evento ragazzi il 30 di marzo quindi a
settimana prossima con che ragazzi
l'evento si terrà il 30 marzo sto punto
ve lo dico e si terrà alla snos comunque
la via e tutto quanto sull'evento che
chrome su facebook
i ragazzi nel caso vogliate partecipare
all'evento che si tiene appunto 30 marzo
credo all'evento su facebook scrivendo
dalla via a che ora che ora lo facciamo
da che ora vado a cagare insomma
comunque lo zero su facebook detto
questo ragazzi vi devi passare alla news
che penso e che penso piacerà a tutti
quanti ma avevi kato sorprenderà tutti
quanti sto per ricominciare una serie
che avevo interrotto tempo fa ma perché
ha prima avevo perso i salvataggi e
quella serie è ben in vista
all'inizio ero questa settimana perché
diciamo che negli scorsi giorni mi sono
mi sono messo lì è rifatto tutto il
gioco da capo fino a quel punto per
poter i commenti di continuare dove mi
ero fermato i ragazzi tranquilli la
faccio poi ragazzi una serie talmente
divertente che non mi prendono neanche
un cazzo di infarto
porca [ __ ] chi me lo fa fare l'ultima
news ragazzi che allora momenti epici
dei videogames su sei è piaciuto un
casino che è stato lo speciale 500 mila
iscritti quindi ragazzi vi ringrazio ma
questo avevo già detto emotivo e mi
hanno chiesto fatima perché c'è momenti
epici the video game 6 e non c'è momenti
epici e video 25 si è passato alla 4 al
5 come mai in realtà ragazzi non è così
ci il 5 io l'ho fatto e l'avevo
pubblicato e molti di voi l'hanno visto
semplicemente non c'è più perché
praticamente me l'avevano oscurato
perché c'è stato un periodo in cui
youtube ha votato copyright su un casino
di video di youtube ma tra i quali ha
colpito anche momenti epici dei
videogames 5 quindi è rimasto oscurato
come i video comunque agazzi non ce l'ho
con quelli youtube perché hanno fatto
sto casino ma ci mancherebbe una cosa
normalissima stare zitto è praticamente
la cosa che gli volevo dire ragazzi e
che ho tolto la parte che aveva il
copyright sul video dei momenti amici
dei videogames 5 e quindi lo carlo
ricaricherò più avanti quando diciamo
quando ci sarà più che altro un buco
perché non si può mettere qualche video
capiterà che lo caricherò in quel
momento lì quindi solo li vedete non vi
spaventate per questo è detto questo
ragazzi devi passare allo scarto dei
pacchi ne apro 3 anche oggi comunque la
cosa ti volevo dire è che è più avanti
di sicuro farò un video nei pannelli
scatto tutti perché sono sto guardando
la perché mi stanno guardando male
quelli che non ho preso mi guardo un
tipo così giunti ragazzi farò un w
avanti tipo blog nel quale vi apro tutti
quanti perché sono effettivamente troppi
chris christie parola porca qua ragazzi
[Musica]
nonché ragazzino ed inviato questa
stupenda ci dicono che sono un sex
symbol non avete non ho dubbi e quindi
ragazzi viene di passare al prossimo
patto che è che è ancora più grande e ho
paura di trovarsi un'altra parrucch
ancora meglio ragazzi mi sta provvedendo
come se non ci fosse un domani sta
parrucca ma non fa niente è che una o
dio se questa regata è un cuscino è un
cuscino cosa mia col mio personaggio
iscriverla wqvga sì mi piace troppo
quando palco questi questi pupazzi
fantastici tra quelli che ragazzi cè un
cd con scritto fa vjd ho paura di vedere
peccato c'è qua da in troppo ho paura
seriamente poi lo vedo vi saprò dire
ecco le ultime ragazzi abbiamo una busta
di marshmallow fantastica con tanto di
scritta chabib anni lui che ragazzi
fatemi sapere se volete che lo faccia di
nuovo tanto sono cosa rispondete che mi
volete bene una donna quanto mi protesto
cosa mi chiama ci hai messo i mid occhi
dentro e che avevo di ragazzi abbiamo
più questo pacco strano che mi piace
tantissimo la forma walker 39 questa è
la figata questa è una figata ragazzi
c'è una cosa c'è scritto c'è una target
600.000 c'è una maglietta con la mia che
ho scritto target 600 mila con una fan
art e sul retro il mio logo phantom e
queste fantastiche grazie mille
detto questo ragazzine che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponde la prima
domanda arriva da alex proyas on 23 ma
vi risponde come fai conoscere così bene
l'inglese sei un mito grazie mille è
comunque allora va bene è una parola
enorme poiché solo inglese come chissà
chi comunque sono abbastanza bravino in
inglese perché sin da piccolo sono
sempre stato su internet e quindi di
inglese l'ho imparato su internet sin da
quando ero piccolo perché comunque se
uno sa naviga tanto tanto tanto su
internet alla fine le cose sono quasi
quasi tutte in inglese
diciamo che ho assunto una padronanza di
inglese abbastanza discreta diciamo non
è che adesso sono un fenomeno comunque
mela cavicchio parti dove siano e
bellezza si fa un pò di chef solo io e
te no è nato prima l'uovo o la gallina
e nato prima a chuck norris oggi puoi
dare un colpo di pistola
mario di red hat shock big match tra i
ragazzi che posso concludere qui con che
ragazzi volevo chiedervi una cosa io
stavolta sì sì come in ogni blog mi
trovo a domande del tipo fa libè vt 1
yogurt a testa in giù una cosa così i
ragazzi se scrivete anche domande serie
oltre a quella io ci rispondo anche non
c'è problema questo ragazzi per evitare
di dare spazio soltanto alle scenette
più che alle risposte normali che perché
ci vorrei vorrei fare entrambe diciamo
bisogna che possono includere qui
ragazzi perché caccia non avete idea di
che prurito alla testa nicchia tra un po
prendo una katana per grattar mela e
direi che posso concludere qui ragazzi
come al solito servito è piaciuto lascia
un commento mi piace anche a parlare di
facebook e come ogni video tratte nella
descrizione ad essere cronisti di
iscrivetevi e noi ci rivediamo il
prossimo mi dò sempre se tre volte al
comando porca [ __ ] dove l'ho messo
cielo perfetto e ogni tanto non lo trovo
perché quando faccio i blog poi non la
vedete la mia camera quando faccio i
blog e non si troverebbe un ca non mi
trovo neanche più io niente ci rivediamo
non possiamo i ragazzi cosa seguito al
risultato comunque mi piace anche a
parità di peso che univideo
dell'università risiede non ci vedevo
proseguito bella ragazzi